the Joe Rogan experience because now
people get to see like hey look John
Jones was out for all that time for
other problems and then for the drug
problems yeah
like this is a lot of money that guy
lost John probably lost tens of millions
of dollars yeah you know yeah he's still
young and he's still you know and hasn't
hit his prime in I don't think no I
think also all that knowing that it can
all be taken away from you probably met
like tempered him yeah like put him in a
better place we realize like I still
have this gift of incredible talent if
he's just a natural-born fighter he just
knows how to fight some guys they have
all the technique all the talent but
they don't know how to put it together
John knows how to put it together yeah
he's just he just that's his that's his
Jam he just goes out there and he can he
just does things on the fly that nobody
would ever think of that works yeah
he tries it's crazy to watch him train
because he's just super lasered in and
focused and there's nothing and you know
there could be the building could be
getting bombed and it wouldn't matter
he'd just be on the bag working on his
technique yeah I believe it it's really
cool to watch yeah well he's he's the
outlier right I mean there's there's
special fighters there are outliers in
in the sport and from our era it was
like Anderson Silva Mighty Mouse John
Jones yeah those are the real outliers
where you just watched me just go Jesus
Christ I can't him when he was in his
prime you would watch him and he would
watch him set guys up and it's he just
it's almost like you had cheat codes
like you could just see what they were
doing you just like you did that I did
this and you do that okay well I'm gonna
do this and I know you're gonna do that
and pop there it goes yeah and he would
just figure guys out it was wonderful to
watch though he opened up them opened up
like a door for all of the rest of us
fight I feel like with any good fighter
when you watch them fight it opens up a
door in your own mind like oh like
that's possible I can do that and so
you're like with Anderson Silva did did
that a lot with his movement with this
head movement with his variety of
punches and kicks and the angles at
which they came in
you know and I don't know I feel like
Anderson Silva did I feel like Rhonda
did that with her judo
I feel like Machida did that with his
karate and then you know I I can go down
the list of everybody but I feel like it
kind of like goes and cycles mm-hmm you
know and I mean it's great for me
because I can watch them and I can
implement new things I feel like that's
why I've been able to be in the game for
so long and still continue to grow and
evolve because I get to watch other
people and the things that they do and
like add that to my to my tool list you
know yeah it changes the expectation of
what's possible right I think it'll
Mighty Mouse that was one of the best
examples of that because when I would
watch Mighty Mouse fight I'd be like
show me someone who's better someone
somebody someone who's ever been better
than this guy like I've never seen
anybody move better than this guy like
he doesn't get hit or if he gets hit he
it's rare like every three or four
fights someone catches him like John
Moraga caught him with a good straight
punch like that that's like that was the
last I remembered I'd like to see him
run it back with the hood oh very close
fire and he kind of blew my mind how
like nonchalant he was about it all like
and he's like yeah but whatever but
that's him DJ is just a special guy
yeah and he's another one's like
couldn't be a nicer guy yeah like if you
didn't know that he was one of the best
fighters that's ever walked the face of
the planet
you go over this friendly guy he seems
he's so nice and normally talks like
he's articulate he doesn't talk like a
mean person
his just it's a great it's a great
example of like something that's
contrary to the stereotypes that people
think of when they think of cage
fighters yeah you know someone who's
fighting it which is a weird word right
like it's do what do you think cage
fighting you do that yeah you're a cage
fighter you do UFC yeah you do UFC yeah
[Applause]